here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and president Trump
hello Abe Iraq why do people keep saying
that speech thinking about my spouse to
pad it I think people are upset that
you're giving him all these shady jobs
in the administration Hey
I pledge to create jobs I just forgot to
bet you they'd all be for one guy
Oh Joey you I'm fine Donald are you sure
yes I'm sure
no no travel problems lately no please
when you and Michelle went to the Virgin
Islands you didn't that's trouble
getting bad right you must've pulled
some strings I guess great with you
we're president did you ever have an
advisor that put an executive order on
your desk and said sign this you dumb
orange tool know did you hear I had a
screening of finding dory in the White
House theater a couple of days ago I
heard about that battle but I believe
there are larger issues we should
discuss Oh
just about all those executive orders I
sighed pretty cool right
I don't think cool is the term I'd use
Steve would he go to base batting said
that for every ten papers outside I get
to watch another cartoon Oh another dead
during this phone call it's gonna be
record Ralph's job tonight did you hear
I fired that lady lawyer you mean you're
acting Attorney General yes and a lot of
people are upset well they should be was
that because it's all just a setup for
she two three when we bring her back for
a retention challenge we see that Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and my bet to see who
gets their job back
fascinating man
you